after months of
jaw-dropping dates and swoon-worthy
kisses this season of the bachelorette
finally came to a close with a lavish
affair and an
engagement with the largest ring in
bachelor history
hey guys i'm leanna aguilera and here's
what's trending on et now
on monday night's season finale of the
bachelorette leading lady andy dorfman
had to decide which suitor stole her
heart over her 10-week whirlwind romance
after sending nick home before the final
rose ceremony
the beautiful brunette decided that
former professional baseball player josh
was the guy for her
gosh i loved you since the moment i laid
eyes on you i've loved you since the
moment i saw you and spoke to you
and out of everything i've been through
i know
i love you i'm madly in love with you
and
your age you're the one that i want to
spend the rest of my life with
and get this josh proposed to andy with
a gigantically gorgeous
4.4 carat nail lane ring making it the
biggest ring in abc's bachelor history
i want her to have the perfect ring i
absolutely love this one
i think this is perfect sparkler is
estimated to be worth a cool 1 million
dollars
and since ending their bachelorette
journey andy and josh claimed to be
madly in love
and couldn't be happier with the outcome
of the show
now that we put the pregnancy rumors to
rest not pregnant
right i'm trying i'm still not pregnant
but it wasn't all sunshine and i love
yous andy's burned ex nick decided to
drop some pretty
intimate details about his relationship
with the bachelorette
in front of the entire country on the
live after the final rose event
if you weren't in love with me
i'm just not sure why
like why you made love with me i don't
well first of all i think that's kind of
below the belt i think that's something
that should be private and
kept private yikes nick see my what do
you think of andy's whirlwind romance
and who else thinks that nick was a
little bit out of line
let me know on twitter i'm at leanne
aguilera and for more news on what's
trending keep checking back to e.t
online